Let's take a quick look
at the layout of the app.
Here are the Java classes.
The Dinner class has methods for
figuring out what dinner to suggest.
The MainActivity shows the main screen.
To start with the main screen only has
this one button, What's for dinner?
And when you press the button
it fires off an intent
to the show dinner activity.
So the dinner shows here and
then you get these buttons.
And each of these buttons fires off
an intent to start the appropriate
activity.
So for example,
the Show Recipe button sends an intent
to start the show recipe activity.
And actually, Choose Again does
not have a corresponding activity,
it just has a method inside the class.
Now this class here,
the useInfoBoxFragment
is a fragment that simply displays
an info box and a heading.
This let's you reuse the fragment
wherever you need it, and
helps simplify the code.
And for example, the showRecipeActivity,
the removeMealActivity,
the orderDinnerActivity,
all these activities use this fragment.
And the app has a couple of menus.
There's the main menu,
which just shows the settings.
But actually, we're not going to use
the settings in this application.
More interestingly, the food prefs menu,
displays a list of food options.
This pop-up is used whenever we want
the user, choose the food preference.
There's one other quick
thing I want to mention.
In the intro lesson to this
course you learned how to
implement the unconnected code to
use the Google API Client Library.
However, for both Google Analytics and
Google Tag Manager,
you do not need to implement any code
to use the Google API Client Library.
All the app needs is to specify
the version of the client library
in the android manifest, like this.
And to specify the dependency on
play-services in the build.gradle file.
And these dependencies have already
been set up for you in the What's For
Dinner sample app.